esta nueva escalada comenzó el lunes de
esta semana cuando israel detuvo a bazán
al saadi un líder de la yihad islámica
explíquenos por favor cuál es este grupo
cuál es su diferencia con hamás y que
los une frente a su oposición a israel
qué tal manera buenas tardes
yihad islámica en palestina es un grupo
tanto político como militante entonces
es difícil separarlo y en ese sentido es
muy parecido a otros grupos de islam
político que ubicamos como hamás como
hezbollah que tienen tanto la parte
política como partidos que ejerciendo un
poder legítimo y la parte militante
yihad islámica palestina es distinta
tiene una estructura separada pero está
muy alineada en términos ideológicos e
incluso de coordinación con hamás quizá
podríamos decir que he had islámica
palestina es un poquito más
intransigente o está menos dispuesta a
negociar que jamás pero en términos
generales son muy parecidos en términos
ideológicos y ambos tienen su principal
el centro de operaciones en casa y tenía
en cuenta que la yihad es mucho más
pequeña que jamás cuéntenos qué tanto
pueden empeorar se los enfrentamientos
entre israel y este grupo militante
un fenómeno muy interesante es que en
los últimos años hemos visto un aumento
bastante sustancial del nivel de
militancia del poder político que tiene
yihad islámica
y sabemos por por cierto que que irán le
está prestando bastante ayuda financiera
a yihad islámica entonces parece todo
parece indicar que tienen algunos un
arsenal pues considerable de cohetes eso
no quiere decir que tenga la capacidad
de enfrentar al ejército israelí ni
mucho menos pero sí yo creo que tiene la
capacidad de continuar
por lo menos haciendo este tipo de
ataques con cohetes hacia israel por por
varios días quizá un par de semanas y es
que la situación continua israel corto
desde el lunes todos los accesos a gaza
que tanto está impactando esto en
implementos básicos como los suministros
de energía y los implementos de los
hospitales
bueno la situación es muy grave desde
antes era muy grave pero desde que
iniciaron estos bloqueos ya toda la
franja de gaza la principal bueno única
planta de energía ya se quedó sin
combustible entonces actualmente y lo
esperamos que siga por unos días esperan
cinco días más de bombardeos por lo
menos toda la franja de gaza se está sin
luz porque la planta sencillamente no
tiene combustible